we're in what a year nine of a
presidential campaign forever yeah
Mitt Romney ran into some protesters
over the weekend did you hear about this
yesterday during a Mitt Romney speech in
Ohio protesters kept shouting Romney go
home yet luckily for Romney he owned
three homes nearby no this one's closer
yeah
President Obama working hard to keep his
job yeah over the weekend President
Obama issued an order that allows some
illegal immigrants to stay in the
country yeah
where was Fox News reported it Obama
issues order allowing himself to stay in
the country
[Applause]
this is crazy however heard this but in
Utah for the first time ever and I
believe it's the first time ever a black
female Mormon Republican is running for
Congress black female Mormon Republican
according to recent polls she has a
slight lead over her opponent a gay
Muslim unicorn named rainbow sprinkle
because that's all unicorns right right
yeah I believe it's rainbow elves
sprinkle yes it is okay how's that cold
by the way well the drugs are working
good
New Jersey Governor Chris Christie says
his blood pressure cholesterol and
asthma are under control now he says I'm
as healthy as every other 600 pound man
from New Jersey you know
the two guys from Chicago left hey get
this Michael writes to them to show that
I'm lying that's called the not true
camera Microsoft made a big announcement
today when they unveiled their version
that there's a huge announcement yeah
they announced their version of the iPad
from Microsoft yeah the actual
announcement was you're probably not
going to buy this know anything for that
thing that's the one like aunts and
uncles will buy cuz they don't get it
yeah it's an etch-a-sketch with a
battery the Nobel Prize Committee
announced they're going to drastically
reduce the money awarded to the winners
they're reducing the money yeah after
hearing this the Dalai Lama said this is
[Music]
put it in the briefcase
feed the dalai lama let's go on the set
of her new movie Lindsay Lohan has been
treated for exhaustion yeah also be also
being treated for exhaustion the guy who
does the bodywork on Lohan's car
I'm acting out an electric buffer right
I that's what I figured this is what
this is this is a buffer sure or you're
sewing down a tree old timey style Oh
with another got another guy that's a
hard thing to Act yeah that's me like
right and we both have mustaches you're
we're bear challenge shirt Oh bear chest
I don't know why I'm walking like that
right I don't know why I'm doing that
that's my new move now on
when I'm getting the applause from the
previous bit I'll start to do this okay
a new brand of frozen burrito this joke
is so important this just in
this just in I tackle the big news
stories they are chilling the card and
see what's going on in the world a new
frozen burritos on the market a new
brand of frozen burrito is being
marketed it's actually being marketed as
a snack for people high on marijuana
that's true
burrito yeah the marketing consists of
just labeling it a burrito
[Applause]
you